- Damn, homey, Randy
put you on blast all over Vine.
- Let them busters talk.
- Aye, yo, fuck this, man.
It's time for
a sneaker-vention, my dude.
Your stank shoe game
is messing with our reps.
- Yeah, even "Free Lunch" Leroy
is clowning you,
and he wears cleats
to school.
- Ya'll trippin'.
My Starburys is vintage.
Popeye Jones rocked these.
- A'ight, that's it.
Show him, Jamal.
- Cindy retweeted
Randy's video, my nig.
And she also left a comment.
- Damn, a smiley face
with tears?
That's messed up.
Maybe it is time for a change.
announcer: This year's
NAACP Image Awards
are brought to you by:
Shackles Footwear.
[man singing blues]
- I gots it!
I gots it!
♪ ♪
[music intensifies]
[whiplash]
[yelling]
- Shackles.
They're off the chain.
all: Oh, shit!
- That's it, my nigs.
That's how I'ma get
my street credit back.
I got to cop me
some Shackles.